hi guys like hi I have John were the
real rejects are the real rejects and
today guys guess what just came out it's
the MTV Awards we're doing that to
matter woman's here and it's gonna be
great by the trailer train rise of the
warrior before anyone asks yes this is
black lip gloss I mean old polish nail
polish what is the hi I got me we got we
got to better like 6:00 in the morning
John and I got pretty drunk sorry we're
a bar sinister onliners not completely
off yet I see God Greg is here goth Greg
isn't like like 20% here I think goth
Greg is actually people really I think
people thought I was way more sure
activist Kasich is like spider-man 3
better when I posted a picture and so
you have people were alive everything
looking borrow that coat any time think
it's a coat the aisle yeah I guess that
might be my new look I'm the new audio
sync are
[Applause]
[Music]
I love this song
I think does not make you a human sure
though what if I promise to be careful
just as you know that diamond does the
[ __ ] no sharp edges
be careful his name
they do not deserve you you've told me
this story
[Music]
yes who are you people we are the bridge
to a greater understanding right well
here's the thing you are in more danger
than you think the boys and the trenches
called her doctor poison boys millions
will die the war would never end
I'm going mother if you choose to leave
we may never return
how will I be a feisty
I
[Music]
I like it doodle or protectively the
wars that way but we got to go this way
first
how can I live fighting this who's this
young woman
she's my
[Music]
dan Kerman Prince Diana Prince
[Music]
if you believe that this war should stop
totally stop it right now
[Music]
you'll soon find out I really love it
it's trailer
[Music]
[Music]
woman witted pg-13 experience at an IMAX
3d June 2nd we got our tickets last week
for it it's not an IMAX but who got her
tickets Tori
boy howdy was that a tree that was a
great great trailer please John I've
said this again every Wonder Woman
trailer lately and I think that and yes
there are nipple chills right now I
really have a lot of faith this this
will be the film that you know I this is
the only one that I've seen or I'm
because the other ones I'm like I had
hope there were some trailers like
suicide spawn BBS it got me excited
every time I see more of Wonder Woman
the more I'm like I wear my fake is just
instill they haven't done anything other
than that supposed thing from WB with
someone wrote about bad problems on set
yeah they haven't done anything in terms
of anything we've actually been publicly
released then that has caused me to have
concern or worry it is this looks great
looks like a very specific tale of who
Wonder Woman is how she became the
legend of Wonder Woman I like the world
war 1 inclusion because I wasn't sure
you know I don't know the Wonder Woman
comics so I wasn't sure like what's she
doing in the war is she just like I need
to help help I'm too exciting with the
US on sure what she was doing but yeah
but hearing about with this doctor
poison is what they called her yeah you
know you got a female villain in here
and a female hero that's awesome and the
Ville and I would like to know a little
bit more about her but hearing that
story is like the first time I've been
aware of it wasn't just the war yeah
exactly so having that even stronger
historical fictional element and fuse
and actually everything was great about
everything looks pretty awesome to me
yeah yeah yeah everything I've seen in
this all the way is shot all the
different sets and stuff like every time
we peer in on a scene I'm like this
looks like a cool scene I like the whole
thing where she's talking to her mother
the Amazonians and stuff like when
you're seeing like her home world and
stuff and like I hope we spend a good
amount of time there cuz that looks
gorgeous and that looks distinct and it
brings color today yeah
you know and then I'm a sucker for for
you know retro war imagery in these
kinds of movies so yeah like I think
it's cool yeah brain her doing the
Captain America tiny thing with this you
know I'm excited to see that her and
Chris Pine look like they're gonna be
great together Chris Pine looks like
he's gonna do an excellent job Calgon
thoughts kickin serious buttocks in here
like this I mean part of the action that
seemed a little off to me was on bullets
are flying at her and she's just like
yeah she's not like really like trying
to block it once I'm at Apocalypse
imagery is a little bit like I hope it
doesn't get way too big at the end like
all of their movies do but hey man if
cuz if i if 80% of it is great i'll be
fine the bar is so low
i don't think this should have any
problems clearing the boat this trailer
gripped me most of the way and like you
I was like this is the first one of
these trailers in a while where I've
just enjoyed it yeah and the only thing
I thought it was the very end when they
kind of got past the point where the
trailer kind of hit its crescendo and
they just showed you kind of a bunch of
really chop it up like cool images when
they do that a lot in trailers sometimes
it gets me concerned when they're
jumping around and a DRN things and like
the fast chop trailers always make me
wonder what they're cutting around
that's just kind of a that's a
superstition I guess yeah yeah so it's
like just knowing what I know about them
I'm still worried for this movie I'm not
gonna be comfortable until the credits
roll but I really hope they nail this
cuz this looks really cool yeah this
looks like really really cool and it
looks like the first one of these DC
movies is gonna embrace some fantasy and
some different stuff than just this sort
of grungy grey and Max feels every
trailer really capitalizes like it I'm
glad Jeff Jones is involved in this
totally because that's what I love about
the flash and I recently started
continuing hero and when I see what Jeff
Jones does with really giving us a hero
like you feel that doesn't climb this
rise of the warrior and whoever it is is
that's a real song that's like before
Wonder Woman or
a song composed for this because that
was I like it's kind of like an easy
cheesy rock and roll song you hear like
a rock I think maybe I'll go with this
this is the first one of these DC EU
trailers that looks like a real movie to
me like even Suicide Squad even when I
thought that looked cool I was still
like this looks like something
zany and it looks like a music video or
like BBS looks like a crazy gargantuan
like a effects explosion this one looks
like a movie yeah and that's what I'm
excited it's a movie that has
high-stakes drama intensity superhero
galore humor I am I really and the humor
looks like it's within what characters
would actually say it do it doesn't look
like force comedy writing yeah not that
the other ones necessarily had that as a
problem well I'm just saying you know a
lot of films and they try to include
humor amp up humor that's what it
usually feels like here the comedy the
the humor seems authentic comes down to
the writing yeah alright paper poops
I'm Greg this is John subscribe to the
real rejects that's numero uno numero
dos click that notification bell so you
can be notified whenever videos up you
might ask yourself why is there a
subscribe button then don't ask me why 3
we launched the patreon patreon calm
slash career video Jack something
getting a lot of love over there at the
new patron community have exclusive
video content and also we have deleted
takes that are uploaded throughout the
week or like you have a few days out of
the week
John is reasons Jerry on Twitter and
Instagram social media manager of Blum
house and the real rejects also double
toasted versus real rejects on the
shutdown no I want you to remember all
these things by the way that I'm telling
you yeah there's gonna be a test on the
next video yeah and number six
happy birthday to I don't knows birthday